we can't fight the reality of where our  customers attention is I understand that  you've done direct mail and you're  comfortable with it and you don't know  how to run Facebook ads it doesn't  change the fact that Facebook ads  perfectly destroy Direct Mail perfectly  every day of the week I understand  you're comfortable with it but it  doesn't mean it's the truth we have to  reverse engineer the reality of the  market that doesn't mean be soft we have  businesses to run as a matter of fact  I'll go the other way the amount of  people that have Labor in their stores  every day and there's nothing going on  if I could control every business here I  would have every person in our stores  that has downtime producing tick tocks  and Instagram and YouTube instead of  standing there waiting for somebody to  come in this doesn't have to be hard  this has to be a reframe of thinking